Every journey is made up of moments. It
begins with the point of departure, a
moment that would become permanently
etched in our minds, the moment it all
began.
When we think back to that moment years
from now it will feel like it happened
in slow motion, like time was frozen still.
We'll try to recall what it felt
like to be in that space, in that time, to
breathe in that air and feel the way we did.
My journey is brimming with moments like
this. Snapshots that capture a dream I
was living. These moments, they're
untouchable.
For some of us, it began when we were 10
years old,
learning about Harvard from watching TV
and determining to do everything in our
power to become a part of it. For others,
it began in high school: growing up in
the shadow of Harvard's glory,
intimidated by centuries of celebrated
alumni. For most, it began the moment we
challenged the assumption that we did
not belong there.
And then there are the hundreds of
images, moments in our memories
accumulated over four years here. If you
have preconceived notions about this
place, throw them away. Harvard is what you
make it. It changes and shifts just as we
do as individuals. How much we mold it is
up to us and the more you shape Harvard,
the more it shapes you.
I've been challenged here. I failed and
I've succeeded.
I've grown. I've experienced moments of
pressure, moments of happiness. I'll never
be the same.
This is our moment. This is the end of
our journey.
And when this moment is gone, our new
journeys begins.